am freitag vormittag treffen
verteidigungsministerin claudia zander
und innenminister karl hammer zu einem
besuch im burgenländischen mannersdorf
an der rabnitz 1
auf einladung des innenministeriums
überzeugen sich die beiden minister von
der reibungslosen zusammenarbeit
zwischen polizei und bundesheer wenn es
um den schutz vor illegaler migration
nach österreich geht
rund 650 soldatinnen und soldaten des
österreichischen bundesheeres sind
zurzeit im burgenland dem
assistenzeinsatz um die stark steigenden
zahlen von illegalen grenzgängern und
deren schleppern in den griff zu
bekommen
2009 10 gab es 358 aufgriffe 2020 haben
sich diese bereits verdreifacht auf 976